hello good afternoon and we start with
breaking news the kovid 19
alert level is to be downgraded moving
from level five
to level four in all nations of the uk
uh following advice from the joint
biosecurity center and in the light
of the most recent data the four uk
chief medical officers and
nhs england national medical director
agree that the uk alert level should
move from level five
to level four in all four nations the
health services they say across
the four nations remain under
significant pressure with a high number
of patients in hospital
however thanks to the efforts of the
public we're now seeing numbers
consistently declining
and the threat of the nhs and other
health services being overwhelmed within
21 days
has receded we should be under no
illusions transmission rates hospital
pressures and deaths are still very high
in time the vaccines will have a major
impact and we encourage everyone to get
vaccinated when they receive
the offer however for the time being
it's really important that we all
vaccinated or not remain vigilant and
continue to follow the guidance we know
how difficult the situation has been
and remains to be for healthcare workers
we thank them for their immense effort
skill and professionalism
throughout the pandemic so that a
statement from the chief medical officer
for
england northern ireland scotland wales
and nhs
national medical director stephen powers
that the covet 19
alert level for the uk has moved from
level 5
to level 4.